i am very very excited because the new
pantone color
just released
and this is very important it's the 2022
pantone color of the year remember this
affects design
fashion beauty
you'll see it affect pretty much
everything in our lives and this year
the color is none other than very peri
which i love because it's a color that
embraces confidence curiosity and a
creative spirit and it's just really
really versatile
so
speaking of versatile i'm going to
demonstrate first how it affects beauty
my brand of makeup is called flower
beauty and we have three periwinkle
stars right here now ironically these
are our best sellers so this is the
supernova celestial skin elixir and what
you do is you can freshen up your makeup
with it
but you can also mix it with your
foundation it is a way to give that
perfect hydration
and i say hashtag wake up your makeup
you won't believe
the effect of this and you can sort of
just dab it on look at that
it's
literally the most refreshing beautiful
thing you can do for your skin i'm not
really a pack on the powder i'm more
wanting to prove that i am hydrated dewy
and i think that looks more youthful
then we have our hydrating lip mask
this is amazing because it just gives
that perfect dewiness and then this is
our supernova um celestial
fro primer now this is what's so cool
about this i love a mousse so i wanted
to make one so you'll see
that it comes out this color and what's
great about periwinkle is it's why they
put it on blonde hair to make it look
not so yellow and brassy periwinkle is a
neutralizer so what it's going to do on
your skin is it's actually going to make
you have a more beige tone
and an overall look that isn't so patchy
and spotty so i mean you put it on and
it just
gives this incredible tone
these are my three can't live without
don't do my makeup without you're each
getting all three of these in the
audience today
so that you can play with them
for yourself and see
the magic because beauty is a feeling
and when you feel like you have good
skin you can go out and think bigger and
better thoughts beyond yourself all
right next up fashion now here to help
me is drew crew member and one of my
dearest friends santa roberts russey
[Applause]
representing first of all you know
corduroy especially a wide whale is
super on trend right now as if i have to
tell you that you're the fashion queen i
mean i'm very very very very perry right
now you actually
i'm loving it though it's funny it's
something you would never really usually
be drawn to because i don't think purple
is at the top of most of our favorite
color list unless you're a
seven-year-old kid yeah my daughter juno
but it actually is pretty flattering
this is literally neutralizing your skin
tone yeah it's very flattering that and
universally it works on everybody as
well which is what's so interesting to
me why i think i'm seeing a lot of
celebrities wearing and now we're going
to be seeing it a lot in the mass market
now for all of us to wear anyone can get
a pop of perry in their own closet
absolutely and here to show us how our
best friends rachel and phil
[Applause]
you don't have to go head to toe like
i'm wearing it can just be an accent so
philly's wearing this awesome crew next
shirt as i said it's an accent not the
whole meal here so you've got the nice
shacket shirt then you've got the ringer
underneath the crisp white sneaker all
together it's just it's there but it's
not too much in your face may i ask you
to take the jacket off yes take it off
okay so the reason i wanted you to take
this off is because i wanted to prove
what a gorgeous color combination
beige and periwinkle is i just think you
look absolutely stunning and i love this
looks right
all right let's go to your best friend
here okay this is a really good way of
showing how
it can look elevated and more
sophisticated and less junior as a color
it's a chic chic blazer and it's one
with just the black like you don't get
more chic than that right the turtleneck
the leather pant the clean shoe all
together i think it looks super elevated
and she looks like it really lights your
face up as well
add on the red lip yeah don't be scared
to add another color with it i like the
idea of doing this really saturated red
lip that's the same intensity as the
purple she's wearing you're a killer
thank you thank you
rachel
all right dana let's move on to home
decor because
now your fashion
and i get all hot and bothered about
design so we wanted to show you an
application in home design
and i couldn't love it more love this i
would have never in a million years even
thought to do my front door in this very
prairie it's got a lot of curb appeal if
you were driving by this would be like
what what is this house what is this all
about right i want to thank you zannah
because um as i drink my very perry mug
i actually vanish if i stand in front of
this yeah i'm just i'm just there blonde
hair
give us a look there yes
very perry is so very very very very
i think 22 is off to a good start when
it comes to our color of the year thank
you santa as always i love you so much
[Music]